[Musique]
le mag au coeur du Salon International
de l'Agriculture bonjour et bienvenue à
tous ici au village réunion 3 degrés
dehors toute la chaleur et toute la
bonne humeur des Outre-mer ici au
premier étage du pavillon 5 Porte de
Versailles le défilé des personnalités
continuent visite aujourd'hui du
ministre délégué chargé des Outre-mer
Jean-François caraco création de valeur
exportation organisation rôle des
chambres on se rassemblent sur le monde
agricole dans tous des territoires des
Outre-mer il y a guyanais
c'est une perspective de richesse c'est
une perspective identitaire c'est une
perspective de création de valeur
perspective de création d'emplois donc
le seul sujet c'est
on se rassemble on prend les mesures
pour être meilleur tous ensemble on va à
la bagarre
avec plus de 600 000 visiteurs attendus
sur ce salon c'est dire si cet événement
populaire est inaubaine pour les
exposants réunionnais c'est l'occasion
pour eux de mieux faire connaître leurs
produits d'échanger directement avec les
consommateurs et de commercialiser leur
savoir-faire certains exposants sont là
depuis plusieurs années d'autres en sont
à leur toute première fois
[Musique]
Marie-Rose vient au salon depuis 15 ans
son cœur de Métis est le géranium mais
au fil des années à la puce et son offre
de tisane de parfum d'épices d'huile de
massage et de passage du de rencontres
pour Marie-Rose le salon de
l'agriculture est incontournable mais en
tout cas
le village réunionnais c'était 89 m²
vous imaginez aujourd'hui c'est 800 m²
et quand on voit la beauté du village
réunionnais je suis fière d'être
réunionnais
notre production à une société qui
travaille de tout le temps avec nous
société Bordas et qui redistribue notre
géranium et nos différentes huiles
essentielles à la grande parfumerie
française on représente différentes
fibres de la Réunion il y a pas de
premier salon pour Patricia mais pas
pour la fédération medi13
ce salon est une opportunité pour
l'artisanat contraint par les coups de
production et par le coût du transport
oui c'est la quatrième fois on a des
affinitaires qui reviennent des
réunionnais un des touristes qui ont été
à la Réunion s'appelait à tout le monde
il trouve les objets magnifiques et le
fait que ce soit de la fibre naturelle
la fibre végétale va tout de suite ça
attire l'oeil c'est du fusil sur les
réseaux des premières participations ici
Porte de Versailles en revanche pour
l'équipe de la Maison Robert
David et Gérald n'en sont pas à leur
premier salon mais ils sont surpris par
l'affluence et l'accueil du public
le salon agricole bon déjà le fait que
ce soit à Paris il y a énormément de
Réunionnais sur Paris donc il profite
bien au salon et ils viennent nous voir
et puis c'est vraiment au niveau de la
communication au niveau des images la
publication des publications des
publicités qu'on peut faire la
visibilité énorme c'est ça qui est
fabuleux les gens sont contents de nous
voir ils sont venus il y en a beaucoup
qui sont venus exprès pour ça et c'est
vrai qu'on s'est fait un peu dévaliser
les trois premiers jours on s'y
attendait pas
que ce soit aussi important mais voilà
les gens sont chaleureux et donc un
grand merci déjà au département pour
pour cette invitation
de la visibilité un espace de vente sur
800 mètres carrés ce salon fait office
de tremplin et d'ouverture au bureau
il en est à sa quatrième participation
ici sur ce salon de l'agriculture
bonjour Jean-Louis Richard du labyrinthe
enchanté alors est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire comment ça se passe pour vous
et comment qualifier cette édition 2020
des très beaux contacts et aujourd'hui
bah c'est vrai que l'espace est très
convivial c'est très spacieux et un bel
espace pour pouvoir travailler est-ce
que vous pouvez nous
gagne le thé de la réunion à être
commercialisé et connu ailleurs que ce
qu'elle a Réunion
c'est de faire découvrir et de montrer
que la réunion peut les produire des
bons produits de qualité tels que le thé
aujourd'hui
pour nous c'est vraiment valoriser les
cultures de la Réunion alors
il y a de visiteurs c'est aussi
l'occasion de rencontrer des
professionnels des fournisseurs viennent
ici nouer contact est-ce que vous vous
avez déjà des personnes que vous
fournissez sur votre territoire
métropolitain et est-ce que vous avez
éventuellement de nouveaux rendez-vous
tout à fait on soigner des fois nous
sommes là on a ramené des commandes quoi
des professionnels même là on a déjà eu
de plus à long là on a déjà deux
professionnels qui nous concrets qui ont
déjà pris des petits commandes avec nous
seuls salons sur Paris et là un qui a
fait des échantillons pour qu'ils
puissent déguster faire son choix sur la
Suisse et ben c'est vraiment de
développer ce marché là et de montrer
que bah le thé ben on en produit et de
très bonne qualité alors
chez vous
c'est notre territoire de La Réunion
bien sûr notre terror aujourd'hui quand
on les montre qu'on aille aussi le label
100% la Réunion ah ben là ça les
garantit que c'est un produit remorque
qui viennent
sur de la Réunion et ce qui recherche va
souvent nous on a nos fournisseur qui
essaie des anciennes bio ils recherchent
aussi cette agriculteurs et ben nous
comme on est labilisés en bio on peut
les proposer ça et ben en plus cette
année comme l'année dernière on a eu la
médaille d'or sur le théâtre et la
médaille d'argent mais il voit qu'on
monte en gamme de qualité et on produit
un petit peu plus de volume mais en
gagnant de qualité donc c'est à dire
pour nous les études c'était moi de
valoriser le thé noir le nouveau TD de
cette année
[Musique]
et comme chaque jour la parole aux
visiteurs de ce salon au détour des
allées ce qu'ils font aussi des produits
est-ce que leur inspire là
mais malheureusement parce que ma paire
tu m'as maman que m'appartient et là de
fois le le stand réunionnais les
produits locaux bah il fait plaisir
franchement merci d'être venu jusqu'à
nous la métropole
de fait découvrir nous notre culture
on va dire subtil et puissant c'est un
super produit en tout cas moi ça me
donne envie de travailler moi je suis
triste de recettes je crée je crée des
recettes et du coup ça me donne vraiment
envie de comme matière première de
l'utiliser pour pour créer des on va
dire des recettes audacieuses
le mec c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on
vous donne rendez-vous dès demain